cuál es la imagen del polígono que sigue
bajo la traslación de m16 ok entonces
necesitamos trasladar -1 en el eje x y
menos 6 en el eje o sea menos 1
horizontalmente y menos 6 verticalmente
por ejemplo este punto que es el menos
3,4
pues ahora pues su coordenada horizontal
disminuiría en 1 sería de menos tres a
menos cuatro y su coordenada vertical
que es 4 pasaría a 4 menos seis o sea a
menos 2 bueno vamos a mover el polígono
vamos a moverlo una unidad a la
izquierda ahí está y ahora 6 unidades
hacia abajo entonces sería una 2
456 muy bien vamos a aplicarle aquí
correcto vamos a hacer un problema más
dice cuál es la imagen del polígono que
sigue bajo la traslación 11 bueno ésta
está fácil nada más tenemos que movernos
uno a la derecha y uno hacia arriba
entonces nuevo este una unidad hacia la
derecha y una unidad hacia arriba
entonces observa que por ejemplo este
punto que era el menos 6 menos 4 ahora
se fue al menos 5,2 3 a cada coordenada
le sumamos 1 comprobamos respuesta y
terminamos